have you guys heard about drunk or Exia
the college kids are all about it now
this is apparently when girls mostly but
guys are doing it to are drinking a lot
more but eating a lot less because they
want to keep the calories low with the
food so that they can drink more we've
got a little more info for you
drunkorexia is most common among
university students facing with
conflicting pressures of heavy drinking
and staying slim all right
realizing that they're gonna have to
drink to fit in but not wanting to put
on any weight drunk or xyx will skip
meals before going out the lack of food
in their system ensures that they get
drunk quicker but raises the risk of
them passing out I mean this sort of to
me seems like it's always been happening
college kids usually don't have a lot of
money I know I didn't when I was in
college I was more of a pothead which
then led to a lot of eating so I guess I
had a different series of problems but
we are so focused on drinking in this
country does that surprise you how
important drinking still is as we again
will talk about the story earlier that
you talked about when it came to people
being freed from their sexuality and
everything right but people now have to
be freed to drink because there's so
much onus on it like you know a
six-year-old kid his parent has the
liquor cabinet and in this country
because a 16 year old can't have a beer
then they lose their [ __ ] when they pass
through town they go well I have to
finish off this whole liquor cabinet
make up last five years and I've been
wanting to take a sip and they kill
themselves by over drinking because we
have this onus on it if we calm down as
a society we can chill out and not to
worry about stuff and normally I would
say yeah this was a country that was
founded by all the people who were too
dull to live in Europe you know and they
still have a lot of weird issues about
this these quote elver are all coming
from the Daily Mail so this is England
where this yes right when I went to
college people used to give blood and
then go drink and then that way they
would get drunk faster yeah they would
literally would literally go give a pint
of blood to the Red Cross I think go to
happy hour because it was you now I've
never heard of drunkorexia
I think I think drunk emia is more
popular which is basically that you know
you have to worry about the calories of
the food reading because you're going to
barf it all anyway yeah but if you want
if you're gonna be drunk or x''k that's
another strategy it's all ridiculous
yeah do you guys think that part of the
drinking reason I think this is what
you're getting to about the kids in the
liquor cabinet
sixteen rows is that our drinking age is
ridiculous for it to be 21 that means
you are allowed to be sent off to war
but you can't drink to vote you can you
can vote but you can't drink I mean this
is craziness right yeah if so then we
get too excited about it so again the
people have to watch that they want to
see what's gonna you know they want to
see what they're gonna be like and but
then again with worry about these beauty
standards again I feel like I'm getting
old cuz it was like a rule in college it
was a rule man they were about to go out
it's Saturday
you better get some food pre hydrate
people know that by the nature of the
fact they're gonna be around other
people who are drinking and that's going
to make them more attractive how much of
college the college experience you guys
think is actually about this stuff about
drink I'm not talking about going
overboard and drink or Exia and that but
you know experimenting with alcohol
experimenting with drugs experimenting
with sex just that so that it's that
part of your life so you can sort of get
it out in a somewhat controlled
environment so that you can go ahead and
live an adult life and not be doing all
this stuff all the time well it depends
if you go to BYU or Bob Jones University
that's not not at all you know right but
for the rest of us who are in the
liberal arts oh yeah obviously there's a
ton of that stuff going on and and I
think you're right I think I think that
it's it is something of a rite of
passage it's our own Rumspringa and you
know you might as well have it in a sort
of safely confined bubble environment
that you're living in so that you get it
out of your system and then you become
an adult and and know what you do and
don't want to do and what your limits
are and how to behave like a normal
person or all that stuff right the
problem is I don't see it changing I
mean it's how does it get reverse now
people always gonna think skinny airs
better and people always gonna think I
need to get drunk or else these guys
aren't gonna have fun with me all this
stuff whatever the belief systems we
have there's no way you can just change
it and sprinkle this knowledge over
society and just think clearly so yeah
well I'm trying to sprinkle a little
knowledge around here last thought on
this how much of this do you think has
to do with just Instagram and the selfie
culture and all that because that's the
body image part everyone's constantly
walking around with this thing in front
of them so you're puking so your abs
look better than your drink like there's
just this constant culture of sort of
making everything about ourselves
that I think is really it's a piece of
this look you know I think if people can
manage to like go out and drink with
their friends and not look at screens
for a while that's pretty that might be
even a healthy thing I don't know you
know what unless you have a final
thought I thought that was the way to do
it go out don't look at your screen
constantly